hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today is an introduction to
fungal pathogens now the study of fungi
is called mycology
and before we start talking about
various important human fungal pathogens
first I want to emphasize that actually
a lot of fungi are good they're
beneficial to humans there are over
100,000 known species of fungi and of
those 100,000 only about a hundred are
thought to be pathogenic there are
numerous good fungi that confer various
benefits so let's talk about those first
first of all fungi are valuable as
decomposers
these are fungi that are in the
environment that help to break down
wastes and dead plants and dead animals
and other things in order to return
nutrients to the soil and then to the
larger ecosystem as a whole also fungi
are useful as a food source this
includes many varieties of mushrooms
that humans can eat also fungi are
essential to the production of various
products for example various varieties
of yeasts which are type of fungus are
used in the production of alcohol and
bread where they serve to ferment sugars
to help with the production of these
food sources and then also fungi are an
important source of antibiotics they are
able to produce antibiotics that are
active against various bacterial
pathogens for example the first
antibiotic that was ever discovered was
discovered by Alexander Fleming when he
was noticing in his lab he had some mold
growing Penicillium species and it was
able to produce something that could
inhibit the growth of bacteria
so those Penicillium moles are where we
get the antibiotic penicillin
so these are the various ways in which
many fungi are actually good for us but
now let's talk about those important
human packages okay so now let's get
into talking about some important human
fungal pathogens I've broken these down
into three categories just to aid our
discussion first let's talk about
opportunistic pathogens what this means
is an opportunistic pathogen is one
where this particular fungus is found in
many humans and normal healthy human
tissues but sometimes if given the right
opportunity it can lead to an infection
called an opportunistic infection
examples of these types of fungi are
Candida albicans and Pneumocystis here
Evette see with Candida albicans it
causes a disease called candidiasis
worth brush
these are infections of the mouth or the
vagina that are result of Candida
albicans fungal infection Pneumocystis
your Apache is what causes you may have
heard of it it's called Pneumocystis
pneumonia
or sometimes you'll hear it referred to
as PCP now these are infections that
occur usually in immunocompromised
patients so in particular
Candida albicans cause infections mostly
in people that are immunosuppressed so
these would be patients with aliens or
newborn babies Pneumocystis pneumonia is
particularly a major danger to those
that have AIDS because they are
immunosuppressed so their bodies cannot
fight these potential pathogens to kind
of keep them in check
it's also possible particularly for
candidiasis infections for this to occur
and normal healthy individuals after
they've taken a regimen of
broad-spectrum antibiotics why is this
this is because as humans we have
bacteria all over our bodies inside our
bodies that are good symbiotic
mutualistic bacteria and one of the
things that they do is they kind of fill
this niche in our bodies where they use
available nutrients and they keep any
other things that are present from
overgrowing but if someone gets a
bacterial infection and then they have
to take a broad-spectrum antibiotic
treatment in order to cure their
bacterial right their bacterial
infection then of course the bacteria
that's infecting them will be treated
and will disappear but also so many of
these mutualistic bacteria meaning that
they can no longer prevent overgrowth a
possible fun fungi that are present so
this is one way in which can
albicans can actually cause an infection
and people that aren't immunosuppressed
now let's talk about another way that
fungal infections can occur in humans
this is through environmental reservoirs
so unlike opportunistic pathogens that
can actually be a part of the normal
human flora and then just cause
infections sort of when the opportunity
presents itself
these are fungal pathogens that can be
establishing an infection in human
following their contraction from an
environmental reservoir so first of all
let's talk about what diseases they
cause there's Histoplasma capsule item
which causes a disease called
histoplasmosis there is blastomyces
dermatitidis which causes a disease
called blastomycosis
and then there is Coccidioides immitis
it causes a disease called
coccidioidomycosis
since its kind of hard to say it has a
common name Valley now how do you
contract these these pathogens
Histoplasma capsule bottom is found in
animal droppings mainly bird droppings
and bat droppings blastomyces
dermatitidis is found in moist soil
Coccidioides immitis is found in dry
arid soils but all three of them are
endemic to the United States and as well
as other countries now how do you get
them from the environmental reservoirs
basically anytime that you are
disrupting the environment so if you are
disrupting the animal droppings or the
soil by gardening or digging or raking
leaves or camping or having a picnic you
run the risk of basically disrupting the
fungal cells releasing them into the
environment and in handling them that
means that the primary type of infection
for all of these these diseases is a
lung infection and the symptoms are
similar to that of flu or pneumonia so
coughing
beaver which can make them difficult to
diagnose if you don't know what you've
been exposed to also all three of these
while they are primarily lung infections
it is possible for them to disseminate
to other regions of the body this is
called becoming a systemic and infection
so they can spread to other organs and
even spread to the central nervous
system if this happens it results in
fungal meningitis which can be a serious
infection
finally let's talk about that third
grouping dermatophytes dermatophytes
caused infections of hair skin and nails
so while these infections are not as
serious some of the other ones we've
discussed today they it's more of a
nuisance so for example this would
include athlete's foot
entering worm
the result of these diseases are that
the infected area is usually red it can
become scaly and itchy but it can
usually be treated pretty easily and
it's not life-threatening so those are
our examples of human fungal pathogens
you can see that there's a lot of
diversity here but before I leave you I
do want to emphasize that there are
species of fungi that infect other
non-human hosts for example there are
fungi that infect plants so Dutch elm
disease and potato blight are caused by
fungi and these have important
agricultural consequences there are also
species of fungi that infect amphibians
so for example Petrecca katrien
denervated s is a fungal species that is
responsible for amphibian declines and
even amphibian distinctions around the
globe so certainly there are many
important fungal pathogens out there
that you should be aware of but that's
it for today thank you for watching and
I hope you learned a lot